hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll this is the
introductory video for what I hope is
going to be a set of short informal
videos short I don't really know but
informal absolutely about what I think
are the biggest ideas in physics in
science and the way that we understand
the natural world in which we live so
the basic idea is going to be every week
I will try to produce one of these
little videos where I pick a big idea
okay space force time something like
that and I talk about it in a way that
hopefully is absolutely accessible to
everybody
there's no prerequisites involved or
anything like that the concepts the
specific ideas that we get too will get
pretty advanced as the series goes on
but there's not going to be any need to
be already a physics junkie or anything
like that to really understand what
we're talking about it's supposed to be
a way to help everyone out there think
about the biggest ideas that we have
when it comes to understanding our
natural world now you might ask why
would I do this for one thing don't I
already have a day job and I do I'm a
theoretical physicist at Caltech and the
Santa Fe Institute I also hosts a
podcast the mindscape podcast and I
write books most recently something
called something deeply hidden about
quantum mechanics in many worlds so I
have a lot going on but there's
something new that has come in right now
of course depending on when you are
watching this you are either well aware
or may not know that we're in the early
stages of the corona virus or kovat 19
pandemic worldwide it is right now March
19th 2020
so we are just now beginning to take
SuperDuper seriously the need for things
like staying at home social distancing a
little bit of self isolation or whatever
you want to call it ways to slow down
the spread of this virus that currently
we have no way of curing or vaccinating
against so this is a spooky surreal
thing for a lot of people myself
included probably less so for someone
like me who very often works at home and
whose work is sort of inward focused
from the start but for a lot of people
who work at regular jobs out there that
might have
down for the epidemic or people who are
just extroverted and like to go out
every night this can be a really really
trying time so all of us are looking for
ways to both get through it ourselves
and to sort of keep connections going
with other people even if we can't
actually go out to a restaurant or bar
or concert or movies and hang with them
okay so my friend Lauren Gunderson who
is a very successful playwright
suggested on Twitter that she was going
to host some playwriting classes on the
internet nothing that was a wonderful
idea so I tried to think about what I
could do that would sort of share some
knowledge that I have in a way they'll
be interesting to people now I don't
have any knowledge that is in any way
helpful to fighting pandemics okay the
kinds of physics I do are not the kinds
that help you understand how viruses
spread or anything like that so I'm not
going to be talking about that I'm not
going to pretend that my knowledge is in
any way relevant to that so after this
introductory video there's not going to
be any more mentions of kovat 19
coronavirus pandemics anything like that
but what I can do is talk about the
physics that I do know and that I know
that everyone likes a little bit but
maybe they haven't had time to catch up
on some of the basics so from my
perspective for my own peace of mind
rather than fretting about the spread of
the virus I get to work on this new
project but I also want it to be a
little bit of a community interaction
project so what I'm going to do is after
every single video I will wait a couple
days I will let questions accumulate
either on youtube or on my blog or on
Twitter or whatever and then I will try
to pick out some of the best questions
and do another video addressing those
questions there's all sorts of different
formats one can take for something like
this right like I thought about just
teaching a high level course with all
the equations and all that stuff but
there's already good courses out there
and also will be work and I think that
the fact that it's work does not bother
me but it would slow down at the whole
process I wanted to dive into something
that I could just do right away with
minimal preparation so if you're
interested in the higher level stuff I
recommend you go to courses like EDX or
Coursera
but they have really really good high
level massive online courses I love
taking these courses you get everything
all the way up to quantum feel
theory in particle physics there for a
slightly more intermediate level check
out the great courses or the great
courses plus I've done courses for them
they're a little bit more slick you have
to pay to get them but you get higher
production values and things like that
we are at the lowest production value
set of standards we have right here at
the biggest ideas in the universe I did
splurge a little bit you know again
keeping myself distracted I'm not sure
as the word but at least something fun
to do while we're in this social
distancing situation
I bought a green screen check that out
hopefully this is working I'm not really
sure even better I figured out how to
write things on a pad on my iPad and put
them on the video so watch this
hopefully this will work
right the biggest ideas we're gonna try
it anyway so while I'm talking during
the videos I will be able to write and
draw little stick figure very primitive
pictures just as if I were talking in
front of a blackboard and you were in a
class or something like that so that's
kind of fun again you know it keeps my
brain engaged we'll see how that goes so
I think this is important in a way or at
least hopefully it'll serve some purpose
okay again I'm not helping anyone
understand how to deal with the virus or
anything like that but I also don't
think that we give up on all of life
when we're in situations like this it is
weird it's unprecedented in my lifetime
to be in this kind of social isolation
situation but we have to both survive
and also move forward a little bit right
we have to get through the day but we
also have to grow and change as human
beings right getting together is
becoming very very difficult right now
but talking to each other over the
internet over technology is something
that we now can do that we couldn't have
done a few decades ago so we can take
advantage of that so of all the ways
that we can continue to grow and
flourish as human beings what better way
is there than to know and learn and
understand just a little bit more about
how the universe works hopefully we'll
be able to provide that a little bit
come back for the next video and we'll
see how it goes